okay bets for doing liberation of Skyrim
there's been talk amongst the go where
do I haven't gotten to look Drago next I
got to go there's this step
wait there yeah we've driven the
Imperials out of Whiterun this is good
very good we now control the center it's
a powerful position while I aim to keep
okay it just [ __ ] quit on me that
[ __ ]
okay i'm opening Skyrim again
no no what that was about it's a
powerful position when I intend to keep
my husband I'm not much of a driven the
Imperial look out of white dodge my
confidence is good he'll call you ice
veins now for the take blood of up here
take this I suspect you'll be of greater
use to us with greater free but I also
want you to find our hidden captain four
feet kalmar will have special tasks for
you you'll be doing whatever gamma tells
you for Skyrim ok you have any news of
the Western horse
let's liberate this yet
you're going they have some I've
sentiment they'll never see this won't
be easy but that's why I'm sending you
all have faith in you rescuing from
partner at Les Dennis
how can I love Hagin ever helped this
was a Radian question that would suck
okay I like here
okay it sucks out on here okay palos
guide you fight remember you I when you
were with us at Hogan and why trial are
you and I have to have Memphis how are
you straight well it just so if it
didn't I say hi then I remember you you
were with us at Helga straight a bit
well it just we found it I need you to
sneak in there and three our men will
stand up should cease fun you should
wait until nightfall before trying to
sneak in Talos preserve last part [ __ ]
it i'm just going on right now
this is the way in
oh and yet afraid of the prisoners you
[ __ ] yes yeah one hit
Thanks let's pcs faster to let her tell
it last but not least let's go and let
Amy episode spot harbor
oh I wouldn't think of that keep up what
you suggest oh that's cool
for the Emperor yeah
hey people are here
good
hair is lat
damn faithless Imperials keep your eyes
open great work get back and report our
success I'll stay here and clean up the
mess glad you were here couldn't have
done it without you
where is all free ah thank you thank you